yesterday Melania Trump unveiled her  official campaign as first lady a lot of  people talking about this it's an  initiative encouraging kids to make good  decisions called be best here's a photo  from her press conference and yeah some  people some people are already saying  that be best is an odd choice of title  and theme but mrs. Trump actually went  through a lot of other options before  she landed on be best here just a couple  that didn't make the cut for example a  literacy program called hello here book  that was one yeah she had a fitness  program called America fat stop no a pet  adoption program called look it dog and  finally an abstinence-only program  called insert they're not there  you  you